A estas alturas, parece que el régimen de Putin
es indestructible. La economía está aguantando
las sanciones comerciales mucho mejor de lo que
muchos se esperaba - Aunque como ya os hemos
contado en nuestro boletín de Patreon las cosas
han comenzado a cambiar con la llegada del 2023.
Sea como sea, Putin ha sido capaz
de sofocar todas las protestas. Y
tampoco parece que sea inminente una rebelión
interna en el círculo más próximo al Kremlin.
Sin embargo... ¿Y si el problema
estuviera FUERA de Moscú? Dicho de
otra forma... ¿Hasta qué punto las regiones
de la periferia del país podrían separarse
de la Madre Rusia algún día? ¿De verdad
es esto posible? Puede que os sorprenda,
pero esta es uno de los mayores
miedos del propio Putin. Atentos.
En otras palabras: que la posible
balcanización de Rusia no es algo
que nos inventemos aquí en VisualPolitik:
es un miedo que tiene el propio Putin.
Y lo cierto es que hay motivos para
pensar que Rusia podría separarse
algún día. Pensad que hablamos de un país enorme,
con un montón de etnias y nacionalidades que
no tienen nada que ver con los rusos de Moscú.
Y no, aquí no sólo hablamos de territorios
como Chechenia. Por ejemplo ¿Sabíais que
la República de Tatarstán, que
es esta región que veis aquí,
estuvo a punto de convertirse en
un estado independiente y soberano?
Y no hace falta remontarse muy atrás en el tiempo:
¡Hablamos del año 1992! Y esto es solo un ejemplo.
Administrativamente, Rusia se compone de 84
entes territoriales diferentes - y eso sin
contar con lo que se han anexionado de Ucrania. Y
las diferencias entre unos y otros son abismales.
Por ejemplo... en el plano económico,
Rusia es terriblemente desigual. Mucho
más incluso que la Unión Europea y
todas sus constantes ampliaciones.
Por ejemplo, el PIB per cápita de
la región más rica del país puede
ser - según el precio del petróleo
- hasta 60 veces más alto que el
del territorio más pobre. Esta diferencia
en la Unión Europea, es apenas 16 veces.
Y la guerra de Ucrania está sirviendo para
aumentar estas diferencias aún más. Y ya sé
lo que pensarán muchos ¡Buenas noticias
para Occidente! ¿Verdad? Pues... ¡no tan
rápido! Una ruptura interna en Rusia
podría desencadenar ser una crisis
internacional de proporciones nachovidalianas.
Pensadlo así ¿Quién se quedaría con el
arsenal nuclear ruso? Como podéis ver,
hablamos de un escenario que, más o menos
probable, necesita que estemos preparados.
Por eso, en el vídeo de hoy vamos a centrarnos
en uno de los aspectos más centrales de la
política de Rusia... y a la vez más desconocidos
fuera de Rusia ¿De verdad Rusia puede llegar a
desintegrarse territorialmente? ¿Pueden
perder territorios? ¿Qué territorios
serían estos y por qué querrían separarse?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas,
pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
T1(LAS FRONTERAS CAMBIANTES DE RUSIA)
Si estudiáis la historia de Rusia, veréis que
hay 3 leyes de hierro que se han cumplido durante
siglos. La primera es que Rusia siempre tiende a
expandirse. Sí, es cierto que muchos otros países
tienen disputas territoriales, pero el
caso de Rusia es especial. Por ejemplo,
esto que veis aquí es la República de Tuva.
Con un territorio equivalente a 3 Costa Ricas.
(Durante casi toda su historia, esta zona
ha estado controlada por China. Sin embargo,
desde 1944 es territorio ruso ¡Ojo! No es
que fuera territorio de la Unión Soviética:
no. Hablamos de Rusia ¡Pero
esperad porque hay más!
Esto otro que veis es la isla de Sajalín, que
es tan grande como todo Austria. Durante siglos,
estuvo dominada por China, Japón y Rusia. Desde
1905, los rusos se la dieron a los japoneses.
Pero, tras la Segunda Guerra Mundial, volvieron
a recuperarla en su totalidad. Y podríamos seguir
con otros tantos territorios: Primorski, Karelia,
Kaliningrado... Pero la expansión de Rusia no
terminó en la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
En 2014, Rusia se anexionó Crimea y,
el año pasado, en 2022, se anexionaron, al menos
sobre el papel, las repúblicas del Dombás. Y sí,
estamos hablando de anexiones. Es
decir, en los mapamundis rusos,
tanto Crimea como el Dombás son territorios tan
rusos como el mismísimo San Petesburgo. Dicho de
otra forma: Rusia continúa moviendo
sus fronteras incluso hoy en día:
independientemente de los acuerdos
internacionales que hayan firmado.)
La segunda constante en la historia
rusa es... la incapacidad del Kremlin
para enviar recursos y servicios públicos a
todos los confines de su territorio. Da igual
que hablemos de la Rusia de los zares,
la Rusia soviética o la Rusia de Putin,
Moscú siempre intenta controlar todo el
país desde el Kremlin... con resultados
desastrosos. Esto provoca un montón
tensiones regionales y tensiones étnicas.
Y esto nos lleva a la tercera
constante en la historia de Rusia:
la tensión entre centralismo y federalismo.
Es decir: dependiendo del momento histórico,
Moscú ha intentado dar más autonomía a sus
regiones... y luego se la ha quitado. Y ahora la
pregunta es: si Rusia puede ganar territorios...
¿Puede perderlos? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
(T2:
¿REPÚBLICAS INDEPENDIENTES DENTRO DE RUSIA?
Si os interesa la política Rusa, hay
algo que os va a llamar la atención:
Chechenia, Dagestán, Sakha… son regiones de Rusia,
pero que se autodenominan como “Repúblicas
Independientes”. Y diréis ¿Esto qué significa?
¿Son independientes o son parte de Rusia?
¿Cómo puedes ser independiente y, a la vez,
parte de un país? Pues bien, aquí es donde
entra en escena este señor que veis en pantalla.
¡Hablamos de IOSIF STALIN! ¡Sí, el mismo
Stalin de los Gulags y las deportaciones!
Cuando los comunistas llegaron al poder, se dieron
cuenta de que hay 2 rusias: la parte central y la
periferia, que tiene etnias muy distintas. Durante
siglos, los zares habían expandido su territorio.
En ocasiones, al ritmo de una nueva Bélgica al
año. Como resultado, había montones de regiones
cuya única relación con Moscú era el tributo que
tenían que pagar... y los jóvenes que tenían que
mandar a las guerras. Por lo demás, tenían una
cultura, religión o incluso idioma distinto
Y ¡No penséis que hablamos
de territorios pequeños!
Por ejemplo, esto de aquí es la República de Saja.
Tiene el tamaño de 6 países como España,
lo que la convierte en la región más grande
de toda Rusia. Y está poblada por los yakutos,
que ni siquiera hablan una lengua eslava. Y
esto que veis aquí es la República de Buryatia.
Es tan grande como Alemania... Y
también tiene su propio idioma,
emparentado con el Mongol. Pues bien, Stalin
entendía que la mejor forma de encajar todos
estos territorios en su nueva utopía comunista
era darles un estatus especial. Permitir que estas
regiones mantuvieran su propio idioma, su propia
cultura y sus propias tradiciones - por supuesto,
la religión era un tema aparte porque eran
comunistas, pero eso es otra historia. Y así es
como nacieron las Repúblicas Autónomas de Rusia.
Es decir, UCRANIA o KAZAJISTÁN eran parte de la
URSS, pero no parte de Rusia. Sin embargo, la
República de Saja de la que hablábamos antes,
por ejemplo, sí era parte de Rusia. Es decir: ley
de hierro número 3: el Kremlin no puede gestionar
todos sus territorios y busca un nuevo encaje...
pero el buenrollismo dura solo una década.
Básicamente, en 1938 el propio Stalin
volvió a imponer el ruso como lengua
obligatoria y comenzaron las deportaciones
y la marginación cultural. Sin embargo,
la figura de las Repúblicas Autónomas se mantuvo.
Y esto es muy importante ¿Por qué? Pues atentos.
(T3: CUANDO RUSIA CASI SE ROMPE)
Unión Soviética, años 90: todo el país está
al borde del colapso ¿Conclusión? Territorios
rusos que se quieren separar del yugo de Moscú.
Para evitar un colapso total, el por entonces
líder soviético, MIJAIL GORVACHOV, aprobó la “Ley
de Repúblicas Autónomas”. El 26 de abril de 1990,
la URSS dio el mismo estatus legal a las
Repúblicas Rusas que a las repúblicas
soviéticas. Dicho de otra forma, que, por
ejemplo, CHECHENIA podría haber roto con Rusia,
pero haber seguido integrada en la Unión
Soviética con el mismo encaje que tenía
Ucrania o Kazajistán ¿El problema con esta ley?
Que meses más tarde, el mismo Gorbachov terminó
anunciando la disolución de la Unión Soviética.
Ucrania, los bálticos... todos esos soviets se
convierten en nuevos países independientes,
pero ¿Y qué pasa dentro de Rusia? Pues
que, en muchas de estas repúblicas autónomas se
preguntan ¿Seguimos siendo parte de Rusia o no?
Si los ucranianos se han independizado...
¿Por qué no los Chechenos o los Tártaros?
Conclusión: que en cada una de estas
repúblicas hicieron sus referéndums
para ver si querían seguir dentro de
Rusia… o no ¿Y qué creéis que pasó?Pues
que hubo repúblicas que votaron por ser
independientes. La historia de Chechenia
ya la conocéis… ¡Pero no fueron los únicos!
Por ejemplo, aquí tenéis el caso de TATARSTÁN.
(Los tártaros son una etnia muy distinta de la
Rusia. Son musulmanes, hablan el idioma tártaro,
que también es una lengua túrquica y tienen su
propia historia y hasta sus propios nombres.
Y, por si alguno se lo está preguntando: no,
no tienen nada que ver con la salsa tártara!
Pues bien, en 1992, los tártaros votaron en
un referéndum de autodeterminación: 82% de
participación y 61% a favor de la soberanía, lo
que la mayoría interpretaron como independencia.)
Como os podéis imaginar, esto hizo saltar
las alarmas del Kremlin ¿Otra Chechenia?
¿Otra región más que se quiere separar?
¿Otra región donde tendremos que mandar al
ejército? Pues… por suerte, en este caso,
Yeltsin consiguió convencerles de que se
quedaran ¿Cómo? Con buenrollismo y negociación
Durante los años 90, el Kremlin negoció tratados
bilaterales con todas y cada una de estas
repúblicas autónomas. Eso explica por qué
cada república haya tenido más o menos
autonomía dependiendo de cómo negociarán
con Yeltsin. En el caso de Tatarstan, como
se querían ir, a Moscú no le quedó otro
remedio que darles más autonomía que a nadie.
Eso explica que, durante más de dos décadas, los
tártaros han podido tener sus propios impuestos o
incluso su propia política exterior ¿Y esto en qué
se traduce? Pues en que la República Independiente
de Tatarstán tiene mejores infraestructuras y está
mucho más industrializada que sus vecinas.
En otras palabras: parecía que Yeltsin había
encontrado la solución para integrar a todas las
etnias rusas en una Federación. Vale, sí, hablamos
de un federalismo desigual… ¡Pero funcionaba! ¿El
problema? Recordad la tercera ley de hierro rusa:
buscamos un nuevo encaje a todos los territorios,
pero el buenrollismo duró lo que tardó en llegar
un nuevo inquilino al Kremlin. Atentos.
(T4: PUTIN Y LA VUELTA AL CENTRALISMO)
Os hago una pregunta ¿Cómo se llama
el partido político de Vladimir Putin?
¡Exacto! Rusia UNIDA. Creedme, el nombre no
es casual. Si hay algo que no le gusta a Putin
es el Federalismo buenrollista.
(En 2004, Putin eliminó la elección
democrática de gobernadores regionales. Cierto,
en 2013 volvió a reinstaurarla pero con muchísimas
comillas. Dicho de otra forma: los líderes
regionales están elegidos, de un modo u otro, por
Moscú. Para que os hagáis una idea, entre 2012
y 2018, el Kremlin reemplazó a 63 gobernadores.)
Y sí, eso incluye a la muy independiente y muy
soberana Tatarstán. Desde 2017, han perdido hasta
la capacidad de tener sus propios impuestos.
En otras palabras: a día de hoy ya podemos
decir que Rusia es vuelve a ser una república
federal sólo en nombre. Todas las decisiones se
toman desde Moscú. Y esto se nota, sobre todo,
en el dinero. Para que os hagáis una idea,
entre 2012 y 2018, los ingresos fiscales
de Kremlin medidos en rublos - que no en
dólares - crecieron un 77% mientras que los de
las regiones solo un 3% ¿Qué significa esto?
Regla número 3: te damos independencia para que
te quedes, y a los pocos años te la quitamos.
Y ya sé lo que pensaréis muchos: tiene
lógica. Un país con tantísimas desigualdades
territoriales necesita redistribución
de recursos. Por ejemplo, el 80% de los
recursos de Chechenia viene del Kremlin.
Pero este centralismo tiene unos problemas
económicos muy grandes. Y la guerra de Ucrania
no ayuda ¿Por qué? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
(T5: QUIEN MUCHO ABARCA, POCO APRIETA)
A día de hoy, año 2023, se calcula que
el 20% de la población rusa no tiene
acceso a agua corriente. Por ejemplo,
en muchas zonas de la República de Saja,
donde pueden llegar a los -40º C en invierno,
tienen que comprar bloques de hielo todos los
días para calentarlos y tener agua limpia. Y
esto explica por qué media Rusia está vacía.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el distrito de
Extremo Oriente supone el 41% del territorio ruso…
¡Y solo el 5,5% de la población! Por supuesto
que el clima no juega a favor de Rusia. Pero
no solo es un problema de clima sino de gestión
de recursos. Y aquí voy a hacer un paréntesis:
el problema de Rusia con el Extremo Oriente da
para un vídeo en sí mismo... y tiene mucha que
ver con la estrategia de Putin de pivotar hacia
Asia. Pero se trata de un tema en el que merece la
pena detenerse y fijarse mucho en los detalles.
Vamos, que es café para los muy cafeteros. Y,
por eso, en lugar de publicarlo en abierto,
lo vamos a reservar para los que nos seguís en
nuestra comunidad de Patreon. Ya sabéis que podéis
apoyar VisualPolitik entrando en nuestro Patreon.
Desde ahí, recibiréis nuestras dos newsletter
semanales exclusivas: las claves de la semana
y LatamPolitik. Pero, además, vamos a subir co
ntenido exclusivo donde tratamos temas con mayor
profundidad para todos los más apasionados de
la política internacional. Así que, lo dicho:
en nuestro Patreon podréis ver un análisis con
mucha más profundidad sobre los problemas de
Putin a la hora de desarrollar la parte Asiática
de Rusia. Pero ahora, sigamos con el vídeo.
Moscú tiene un problema de proporciones
nachovidalianas a la hora de llevar
infraestructuras a todo el país. Por ejemplo…
algo que os va a sorprender ¡Rusia apenas tiene
puentes! Mientras Estados Unidos tiene
alrededor de 600.000 puentes, Rusia,
que es 1,7 veces más grande, tiene alrededor
de… 42.000 puentes. Eso se traduce en zonas
del tamaño de toda Europa Occidental donde es casi
imposible encontrar trabajos. Y diréis ¿Pero por
qué no pueden construir infraestructuras? Pues
vamos a ver un ejemplo: el puente de Yakutsk,
la capital de la República de Saja.
Este proyecto se frenó en seco en el
año 2014 ¿Por qué? Pues porque justo ese año
es cuando Rusia invadió la península de Crimea.
De repente, la prioridad del Kremlin pasó
a ser el desarrollo de su nuevo territorio:
Crimea. Casi todo el dinero se fue para proyectos
como el puente de Kerch, que conecta Crimea con
el resto de Rusia. Eso y proyectos faraónicos
como los Juegos Olímpicos de Invierno de Sochi:
uno de los más caros de la historia. Solo
en este proyecto, el Kremlin se dejó más de
16.000 millones de dólares: casi el doble de los
9.000 millones de dólares que pensaban invertir
para desarrollar el distrito del Lejano Oriente.
¿Entendéis por dónde voy? Ahora el Kremlin tiene
poder casi ilimitado para gestionar
todo el presupuesto de Rusia. Y ahora
Putin tiene otras prioridades por encima de
desarrollar todas las regiones. Por un lado,
necesita incrementar el gasto militar.
Por el otro, necesita mantener las cuentas
controladas ¿Conclusión? Muchas regiones están
quedando marginadas. De hecho, se calcula que,
para 2024, el 68% del PIB de toda Rusia venga
solo de las 12 regiones más prósperas ¡Pero
no solo hablamos de dinero! También hablamos de
vidas ¿De dónde creéis que vienen la mayor parte
de las bajas de la guerra de Ucrania?
Pues fijaos en esta aproximación que,
seguramente se quede corta, pero que nos dicen
por dónde van los tiros, nunca mejor dicho.
En el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo, Moscú
ha perdido a 98 soldados. Si tenemos en cuenta que
Moscú tiene 13 millones de habitantes, podemos
decir que la mayoría de las familias moscovitas
duermen tranquilas. Ahora bien ¿Qué pasa en otras
regiones como... la República de Buryatia? En este
caso, hablamos de 452 caídos... Es decir,
que por lo menos 1 de cada 2000 habitantes
ha muerto en la guerra. En otros sitios como la
República de Tuva encontramos cifras parecidas.
Dicho de otra forma, que cada vez hay más gente en
estas regiones que conoce personalmente a caídos
en la guerra. Una guerra que se está produciendo
a miles de kilómetros de distancia. Pensad que la
distancia que hay entre la República de Tuva
y Ucrania es la misma que hay entre España y
Armenia. Y todo esto explica que estén empezando a
surgir movimientos de autodeterminación. De hecho,
en 2022 nació el Foro de las Naciones Libres
de Rusia, donde se están empezando a organizar
varios movimientos separatistas ¿Cómo de grande
es esta organización? No lo sabemos ¿De verdad
vamos a ver un movimiento separatista en Rusia? Es
muy pronto para decirlo... y, de darse algo así,
podría ser dentro de muchos años. Como decimos
siempre: en VisualPolitik no podemos predecir
el futuro. Pero sí podemos decir que los
problemas de la Rusia zarista persisten en
la Rusia de Putin. Y, de igual forma que Rusia
ha tenido tensiones étnicas en el pasado, podría
volver a tenerlas en un futuro no tan lejano.
En cualquier caso, hay un montón de temas que
hemos tenido que dejar en el tintero. Si queréis
saber más sobre este tema, os esperamos en nuestro
Patreon. Mientras tanto, ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros ¿Veremos una nueva oleada de movimientos
separatistas? ¿Será capaz Rusia de encontrar
otro nuevo encaje a todas estas repúblicas?
En caso de que no fuera así... ¿Qué pasaría con
todo el arsenal nuclear Ruso? ¿En manos de quién
quedaría? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios. Y como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí,
en VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. Un saludo y hasta pronto.